MICHAEL, I WANT TO ASK YOU A
QUESTION, AS AN OUTSIDER, YOU
SPENT A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME AS BIOGRAPHER OF DONALD
TRUMP WITH HIM AND FAMILY
MEMBERS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING
THROUGH THEIR MINDS AND THEIR
LIVES?
>> I THINK THEY'RE DELIGHTED.
I THINK THEY'VE BEEN PLANNING
FOR THIS FOR YEARS.
DONALD TRUMP FIRST DID HIS
REACTION TO THE FBI ACTUALLY
HAVING HIS LAWYER CALL THEM
GESTAPO AND STORM TROOPERS 50
YEARS AGO.
SO, HE'S BEEN PREPARED FOR THIS
STRATEGY ALL ALONG.
HE ISSUED CAMPAIGN-STYLE
COMMERCIAL WITHIN HOURS.
THIS WAS PREPARED IN ADVANCE.
SO, HE'S AN EXPERT AT SPINNING
EVERYTHING INTO PUBLICITY.
HE BELIEVES ALL PUBLICITY IS
GOOD PUBLICITY.
AND THAT HARDCORE TRUMP GROUP,
35% OF THE ELECTORATE, IS GOING
TO BE ELECTRIFIED BY THIS.
I THINK HE'S HAVING A GOOD DAY,
ACTUALLY.
>> YOU SEE THIS AS SERIOUS ON
MANY LEVELS?
>> I DO.
I DO.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT BEING
VITAL NATIONAL SECURITY
DOCUMENTS.
I DON'T THINK WE CAN FORGET,
THAT THOSE -- EVEN IF TOP SECRET
THOSE CAN POSE A GRAVE NATIONAL
SECURITY RISK IF IT'S IN THE
WRONG HANDS OR LAID OUT TO THE
PUBLIC.
I HOPE THIS DOES NOT COMPLYING
WITH LAWS, DOJ JUST HANDED TRUMP
POTENTIALLY THE PRESIDENCY.
IF IT'S SEEN AS A MASSIVE
OVERREACH OR SOMETHING
INCREDIBLY SERIOUS, THIS IS A
GOOD DAY FOR DONALD TRUMP.
BY THE WAY, HE KNOWS HOW TO PLAY
THIS UP IN HIS FAVOR.
HE MORE OR LESS BROKE THIS
THING.
>> HE DID BREAK IT.
>> YEAH, A FLORIDA-BASED
REPORTER HAD SOMETHING.
BUT HE WAS READY TO GO, I'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN QUITE OF A LINE OF
MESSAGES AMONG REPUBLICANS.
THIS IS A BANANA REPUBLIC, THIS
SHOULDN'T HAPPEN, IF THEY DO IT
TO A PRESIDENT, THEY'LL DO IT TO
YOU.
I THINK HE'S HAVING A GOOD DAY.
>> THAT'S INTERESTING, THE
MESSAGING FROM REPUBLICANS
THEY'RE SEEING THE BENEFITS
GOING INTO THE MIDTERMS?
>> UNLESS IT'S DeSANTIS OR
ANYBODY ELSE PLANNING ON RUNNING
FOR THE REPUBLICAN NOMINATION IN
2024.
LOOK, THIS JUST HAPPENED.
SO THE RAMIFICATIONS ARE STILL
COMPLETELY --
OR MOSTLY UNKNOWN.
BUT IN THE SHORT TERM, WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE IS EXACTLY WHAT
ALISSA SAID.
I DID NOT TELL YOU HOW MANY
REPUBLICANS I HAVE TALKED TO WHO
SAID JUST THE POLITICAL WAY HE
HANDLED THIS, VINTAGE TRUMP.
AND FOR HIS SHORT-TERM POLITICAL
GOAL WHICH IS IF IN FACT HE GETS
THE REPUBLICAN NOMINATION KIND
OF GENIUS.
LOOK AT THE BUZZWORDS HE USED IN
THAT STATEMENT, "OCCUPIED,"
"RAID" BASICALLY SAID IT WAS THE
DEEP STATE WHICH TOTALLY
TRIGGERS AND ANIMATES THE PEOPLE
NOT ONLY WHO LIKE HIM, BUT THERE
WAS CONCERN, ACCORDING TO PEOPLE
AROUND TRUMP, THAT HE HAD, THAT
HE WAS LOSING SOME MOJO.
HE WAS HAVING SOME TROUBLE
RAISING MONEY.
AND THIS, HE BELIEVES, WOULD
TURN IT AROUND.
>> I MEAN, HE HAS FORESHADOWED
THIS EVERY STEP OF THE WAY FROM
MUELLER, EVERY STEP OF THE
INVESTIGATION WAS A POLITICAL
HOAX.
WE ALL KNOW THAT IF DOJ DID
ANYTHING THIS WAS GOING TO BE
THE RESPONSE.
I DO AGREE WITH ALYSSA THAT THIS
WILL LOOK BAD IF THIS IS DOTTING
THE Is, CROSSING THE Ts TYPE OF
THING ON DOCUMENT CONCEALING
CRIME.
I SUSPECT IT'S NOT.
FIRST OF ALL, THEY GOT 15 BOXES
THERE.
THEY DID DISCUSS IT IN JUNE --
>> 15 BOXES IN JANUARY.
>> IN JANUARY, THEY TALKED
ABOUT, AND HAD SOME DISCUSSIONS
IN JUNE, I WOULD GUESS, THIS IS
SPECULATION, BUT FROM MY
EXPERIENCE AS A FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR, I WOULD SUSPECT THAT
DOJ HAS VERY GOOD INFORMATION
FROM A WITNESS THAT THERE IS
MORE THERE.
AND THAT'S WHY THEY DID THE
SEARCH WARRANT.
REMEMBER, THIS IS A GUY WHO IS
FLUSHING DOCUMENTS DOWN THE
TOILET.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GO ASK HIM
TO TURN SOMETHING OVER.
SO, YOU HAVE TO DO A SEARCH
WARRANT.
AND I DON'T THINK THEY'RE DOING
A SEARCH WARRANT JUST SIMPLY TO
SORT OF BUTTON UP THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK THEY WOULD ONLY DO THIS
IF THEY HAD REAL EVIDENCE --
REAL INDICATION OF SOME
EVIDENCE.
>> AND TO BE CLEAR, WHAT I JUST
DESCRIBED IS THE POLITICAL
ARGUMENT.
AND WHAT IS GOING THROUGH HIS
MIND ABOUT HIS POLITICAL FUTURE,
WHICH HE SEES IS VERY MUCH TIED
TO THE LEGAL STRATEGY, BUT,
YOU'RE RIGHT, THAT IT'S REALLY
HARD TO IMAGINE, ESPECIALLY
GIVEN WHAT WE HAVE SEEN, WITHIN
THE DOJ, OVER THE PAST, YOU
KNOW, SEVERAL YEARS, THAT THEY
DID NOT DO THIS WITHOUT IT BEING
BUTTONED UP AND BEYOND.
JUST THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES OR
THE DOCUMENTS THAT HE TOOK,
UNLESS IT'S REALLY RELEVANT TO A
LARGER SENSE.
>> AND I DO THINK THE
SPECIFICITY OF THE RAID, KNOWING
TO LOOK IN THE SAFE, IS SOMEBODY
WHO IS COOPERATING, SOMEBODY WHO
KNOWS WHO IS CLOSE TO THE TRUMP
CIRCLE AND KNOW WHERE IS THEY
SHOULD BE LOOKING.
WE DO KNOW THAT, A HANDFUL OF
FOLKS HAVE GONE IN, IN RECENT
WEEKS AND IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THEY'RE COOPERATING.
>> IT'S POSSIBLE, I'VE SEEN THE
SIGNALS WITH IVANKA TRUMP
ACTUALLY SAYING I'VE TAKEN THE
RED PILL WHICH IS A CALL-OUT TO
THE PARANOID, ONLINE MEME-BASED
EXTREMISTS.
AND DONALD TRUMP JR. HAS
ESPECIALLY THIS IRON CROSS
CRU
CRUSADER CROSS ON THE STOCK OF
HIS GUN AND DISPLAYS IT
PROMINENTLY.
THIS IS SAYING TO THE BASE WE
AGREE WITH YOUR PARANOIA.
>> AND WE'RE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION HERE, AND WE'RE
GETTING REALLY ONE SIDE OF THIS.
>> YES.
>> AND IT'S FROM TRUMP WORLD.
IT IS FROM TRUMP WORLD.
YES THERE WAS THIS POLITICAL
JOURNAL IN FLORIDA THAT HAD A
HINT OF THIS BUT IT WAS DONALD
TRUMP WHO MADE THE STATEMENT AND
TRIED TO CONTROL THE STATEMENT
EARLY ON.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THE DOJ.
>> RIGHT, WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
THE DOJ.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS WHO DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
THEY'RE SPOUTING OUT, FOLLOWING
DONALD TRUMP ATTACKING THE DOJ,
WITHOUT ANY IDEA WHAT THE BASIS
FOR THIS SEARCH WARRANT IS.
AND IT JUST GOES TO SHOW YOU HOW
MUCH CONTROL DONALD TRUMP STILL
HAS OVER KEVIN McCARTHY AND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
AND THE FACT THAT KEVIN McCARTHY
WOULD ISSUE THAT STATEMENT, IN
SUCH AN ANTAGONISTIC AND
INFLAMMATORY WAY AGAINST MERRICK
GARLAND, I WONDER IF HUNTER
BIDEN IS CHARGED ARE WE GOING TO
SEE HIM WITH THAT SAME KIND OF
PRESERVE YOUR RECORDS?
OF COURSE NOT.
HE'S CONSISTENTLY UNDERMINED THE
RULE OF LAW.
AND MERRICK GARLAND.
>> LET ME ASK YOU, MERRICK
GARLAND MUST HAVE KNOWN THIS
TYPE OF THING WAS COMING, LISA
MONACO MUST HAVE KNOWN THIS TYPE
OF RESPONSE WAS COMING,
CHRISTOPHER RAY MUST HAVE KNOWN.
HOW MUCH DOES THAT RAISE THE
STAKES FOR THE DECISION?
WHAT BAR DO YOU THINK THEY MELT
W
FELT WAS MET?
>> I THINK THEY HAVE TO KNOW IT
WAS MEANT FOR THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
THEY ABSOLUTELY KNEW THEY WERE
GOING TO GET THIS BLOWBACK.
BUT I THINK MERRICK GARLAND HAS
BEEN RIDICULED FROM THE LEFT FOR
GOING SO SLOWLY.
EVERY TIME HE GETS RIDICULED, HE
SAYS, WE WILL FOLLOW THE FACTS
AND THE LAW WHEREVER IT LEADS.
AND I THINK HE'S GOING TO DO
THAT.
BOTH SIDES ARE NOT GOING TO LIKE
IT.
HE'S GOING TO GET ATTACKED.
I THINK HE PROBABLY HAS SAID,
YOU KNOW WHAT, THIS IS MY JOB,
I'LL GET ATTACKED.
>> CAN I JUST ASK YOU THAT, IT'S
NOT AS IF THEY JUST WOKE UP AND
SAID, OKAY, TODAY'S THE DAY.
WE'RE GOING TO EXECUTE THE
SEARCH WARRANT AND GET THE FBI
WHAT THEY WANT.
THIS HAS BEEN THE CLIMAX OF
MONTHS AND MONTHS AND MONTHS OF
ACTUAL TALKS BETWEEN FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS AND DONALD TRUMP'S
LAWYERS.
OUR REPORTING IS THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HIMSELF EVEN WENT INTO
A MEET THEY GO WERE HAVING AT
MAR-A-LAGO ABOUT THIS.
SO, HE'S BEEN DRAGGING IT OUT.
AND THE QUESTION IS WHY?
THE QUESTION IS WHY?
WHY HAS HE NOT LET HIS LAWYERS
SAY, OKAY, OKAY, HERE ARE THE
DOCUMENTS YOU'VE BEEN ASKING
FOR.
>> WELL, I DO THINK DOJ IS GOING
TO HAVE TO SAY SOMETHING, WHILE
THEY DON'T COMMENT ON ACTIVE
INVESTIGATIONS JUST LEAVING THIS
OUT THERE LETS THIS SORT OF
MOMENT THAT YOU REFERRED TO IN
THE COUNTRY JUST PERCOLATE AND
SEE MORE AND EXTREMISTE IST RHE
ON DIFFERENT SIDES.
EVEN DONALD TRUMP'S CANDIDATES
ARE COMING TO IT AS A WITCH
HUNT.
I'M NOT SURE YOU CAN LET THAT
HANG OUT THERE WITHOUT DOJ
GIVING THE PUBLIC A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION ON WHAT'S GOING ON
AND WHAT LED TO THIS.
>> BUT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
HANDCUFFED IN THIS WHOLE PROCESS
BECAUSE EVERYTHING SAID BY THE
GOVERNMENT WILL BE DISCOUNTED BY
TRUMP.
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO FOLLOW HIS
LEAD.
THIS IS GOING TO BECOME ONE OF
THOSE TERRIBLE INCIDENTS, WHERE,
AS YOU SAID, IT'S GOING TO GET
DRAGGED OUT FOR A LONG TIME.
IT IS DANGEROUS.
YOU KNOW, THESE FOLKS ARE OFTEN
INSPIRED TO PLAN VIOLENCE, OR
CONDUCT VIOLENCE.
SO, I THINK TRUMP IS, AGAIN,
PLAYING WITH FIRE.
BUT HE'S ALWAYS PROVE THAN HE'S
WILLING TO DO THAT.
AND HE'S GOING TO DRAG THIS OUT.
HE'S AN EXPERT AT DRAGGING IT
OUT.
>> RIGHT.
>> DOJ AND THE FBI WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO SAY ANYTHING
SUBSTANTIVE.
THEY WILL SPEAK THROUGH THEIR
PAPERS.
I DO THINK WE WILL SEE, PROBABLY
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER, THE
AFFIDAVIT UNDERLYING THE SEARCH
WARRANT WHICH WILL LAY OUT ALL
THE EVIDENCE.
>> HE ALSO HAS THE LYING
ADVANTAGE.
THE GOVERNMENT IS NOT GOING TO
LIE BUT DONALD TRUMP LIES
PROFUSELY.
>> WE SAW THAT IN THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
>> HOW DOES THIS AFFECT HIS
CALCULUS ON THE ANNOUNCEMENT,
ALYSSA?
>> I THINK HE JUST SPEEDS IT.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE THIS SERIES
THAT YOU CAN'T INDICT A
PRESIDENT AND PUSH IT AS A
CANDIDATE.
HE'S GOING TO ARGUE THAT HE'S
THE FRONT-RUNNER FOR PRESIDENCY.
AND THAT'S GOING TO SPILL OVER.
I THINK HE'S MOVING UP HIS
ANNOUNCEMENT.
SAYING THIS IS A GOOD DAY WITH
THE BASES TO RALLY AROUND HIM.
>> ONE SMALL FACTOR IN HIS MIND
YOU THAT KNOW, AS SOMEBODY WHO
HAS WORKED IN POLITICS BEFORE,
THE MINUTE HE ANNOUNCES, HE
LOSES A BIG MONEY TRAIN.
AND THAT IS THE MONEY THAT IS
COMING FROM A JOINT AGREEMENT
WITH THE RNC THAT HELPS HIM PAY
HIS LEGAL BILLS.
AND HIS LEGAL BILLS ARE NOT
SMALL.